okay
for people joining this live stream this
is a design review
for orphan language version 12.2 which
is coming soon
i hope and this is about optimization
optimization in the sense of
mathematical optimization not in the
sense
of code optimization and i guess we have
a bunch of new features here can you um
can you introduce this yeah so
um you know we've in 120 and 12
1 we've been developing
whoops roger you fuzz the framework for
convex optimization so these
convex optimizations are sorry you
[ __ ] acceptable
okay convicts optimizations is
fast both in theory and in practice
and it's global so it's a basis
for many of the future optimization will
do
overall so this time around we have
extensions to that
so the first part here says that we can
do those optimization
over complex variables in twelve one we
did integer variables
which is um wait we've done real
variables
real variables is the defaults so it's
it's it's always there
um then we extended what's called
combinatorial or
integer variables yep uh in 121
now that's that's a different kind of
difficulty um
so what functions does this flow into i
mean this flows into maximize minimize
does it flow into
i mean is it relevant for like neural
net training and things like that or is
it not relevant for that or does nobody
know
or what's the story
so well i mean
this this currently flows into um
all the convex related optimizers i
understand that i'm asking about things
outside of the
outside of the optimization bundle in
the system i'm asking about completely
different functions and image processing
or something else i mean
where does this get used oh optimization
gets used you mean
yes oh okay yes
so they get used you know heavily in in
statistics
uh anything so we're using the latest
our latest stuff when we do a fit of a
curve we're using our latest
optimization functions we actually do so
one of the things that we did in 12-0
and
rob can speak to that better is that we
upgraded all these fitting functions
not the statistical model fit function
because that's a
that's another but so find fit for
example is using
fancy modern convex optimization is that
true
when it can but we also have i mean one
of the things we added to fit
in 120 was was fit with regularization
um what does that mean so so so
so that the classic the classic fit is
basically
least squares of you know why is that a
convex optimization problem
it is but but it's actually but you can
solve it simply as a linear algebra
problem
so that's but but if you add for example
if you
add a you know norm of x
uh one so the one norm of x to that
what you do is you actually get a sparse
you get a sparse set of the basis that
best
best does the fit and that is a convex
optimization problem
but so wait a minute so let's say we
were fitting numbers with errors
is that still linear algebra or does
that require something fancier
mean by that well i mean you you have a
weighting based on the error bounds
it's just a waiting then it's still the
same problem
okay but so you're saying an l1 norm
rather than an l2 norm
well no no no no no let's go to the page
okay if we're going to talk about that
so the thing is that when you when you
fit these coefficients and stuff
the question is do you want to let these
coefficients get arbitrarily big
or do you want to penalize lots of big
coefficients
if you penalize the big coefficients
it's called regularized fitting and they
have a bunch of fancy names like lasso
and so on okay so people often know them
by those
uh you know kind of names so if you go
to fit for instance well it's also
called
i mean the it's called so called basis
pursuit or ridge regression
yeah depending on you know depending on
how you penalize them they have
different names
fit regularization oops
where it's examples that's missing
why are they missing i don't know why
oh you mean a building fell through the
cracks or it's a bill problem
okay so people might know them by these
names instead no that's fine i mean
there's a lot
of pity that the examples fell off
that looks good so is this also
supported in find fit
for non-only footing yes well well so so
if you give fine fit a linear model
it'll automatically use these and you
can but what if what if we give it a
non-linear model of that nonlinear model
yes you can also you can also use the
fit regularization but it's not
necessarily
not necessarily going to be a convex
problem so it may also we don't
necessarily have a global solution but
we do
we do support the regularization
so question here um
um yeah so there was a goof up with fed
regularization it's even
wrong on the web um
[Music]
okay so the question here uh
right so basically we're we're using the
fanciest
optimization methods we can when we can
use them
oh oh oh let's ask you know let's i mean
your original question where is it used
in our system so it's gradually making
its way into more and more parts of the
system okay um
so there's one thing that we looked at
yesterday for instance these
minimum volume ellipsoid bounding
regions yep
that's using our best optimization
okay um there's a bunch of graph um
operations that we have added and
they're a bunch on the to-do list that
will also be
just uh basically uh optimization what
about
graph layout graph layout is an
optimization problem but it's
as a dedicated solver so
this is the the the other thing that
happens when you have
if you can so what we develop are
general purpose
optimization you're saying
you're saying spring electrical
embedding could work this way but we
shouldn't have it do that because we
have a completely optimized piece of
code for that particular case
exactly fine but it was written by our
previous you know
optimization team that knew exactly
what's what needs to be optimized to get
it to that level of performance
i'm saying right for that problem but
okay so you've done a scan of the rest
of the system
like image processing or something you
know like i don't know
yeah i have a we're flowing this in
gradually
partly by us doing sometimes prototypes
we've done a bunch of prototypes in this
team
partly getting you know in the teams
to to be trained up to see what's
available
and they see it and so then it's a
question of when it sort of fits with
the
you know some some mix of this
opportunity is big enough we should do
it now
because it's easy it's available versus
let's do it when we come to that point
and we know that we can now utilize this
what about things like labeling on on
plots and labeling of so labeling that's
also an optimization problem but it's
it's it's it's um it's not using convex
optimization
it's it's um you know because
some of the things that you need to to
to test there i mean it's also
it's not convex to begin with okay all
right fine so so
okay but yeah yeah our our system is
full of optimization problems and
many many many more will be there in the
future all right i'm just checking that
you're going through and making sure
that all this stuff
flows in correctly yes okay and there
are many many things on its way
let me make a trivial silly comment for
um maybe avery can note this down
there are these black lines between
these these rows
i don't think they've been there before
screen capture
ask design they look wrong to me
something went wrong here
okay somebody can you do that please
what do i yeah should i do it yeah i
just i just screenshot it okay all right
fine
okay optimization solver extension api
so here's the idea i understand
i think i understand the idea you can
plug these in as as the core
optimization thing
ins once we have presented once we've
processed the problem to the point where
it can be fed to these things
right right and anybody the idea is that
anybody including companies
should be able to write these yeah i
understand so if you're an academic yeah
i i got it i got the
i got the idea right so the question is
do these things have file formats
or is there is that what is the i mean
they do have file formats but we
don't want to communicate with them in
that way because it's it's very
so what is the api where was the
documentation for the api
you said documentation yeah there is
there but it's done as a packet so i
don't think it's accessible
do you want to show it to me on the
screen yeah rob can share it
okay um go ahead let me pull it up um
so
um i mean i
assume that's why you put it on this
agenda yes
okay yeah this is not totally refined
yet but
um okay
yeah am i sharing okay go ahead and show
oh okay it didn't work okay go ahead and
show
okay that should work now
um
it'll take me a little while to get
there
um
oh dear me um okay you know what
let's go on yeah are you ready for it or
not
no let me get it go on and i'll i'll get
it ready
okay so let me unshare and then uh
when i want to have it ready i can let
you see it
okay all right okay what's next in this
agenda
okay so then there are two you know so
so the other thing that we've extended
for these to work on complex numbers
complex vectors okay you said that you
said that you said that
what the next step hold on okay the next
big thing is that we're dealing with
parameters
so you do an optimization problem and
you have
parameters where those parameters can
attain some range of values they live in
a set
basically okay so the two
things we have here is robust and
parametric optimization and there's a
third coming called stochastic
optimization
so let me the easiest to explain first i
think is actually parametric so maybe we
should go there for
first so the idea is this you solve this
is set up to be able to solve
optimization problems parametric
function
this is the thing that we created for
parametric and dissolve and it returns
a function that takes parameter values
and given those parameter values it goes
ahead and solves and gives you the
actual solution
which is typically there are other
places we should be using this is the
machine learning group
aware of this function it's been there
forever i know it's been there forever
but i don't think they're aware of it
probably
um i mean we really should be thinking
about whether where else this can be
used
yeah i remember this now yeah so so our
design i mean it's quite separately from
this
you know so we have tentative design for
parametric functions for more survivors
numeric solvers
this is now for optimization so the idea
is there is a parametric
family there's a family of things that
say parametric blah blah blah
that return a parametric function which
when given the parameter values gives
you the actual solution for those
because then it's a fully numeric thing
but it does a second thing which is
actually crucial
because you can now compute the so so
that first thing of repeated solving
efficiently
people were using that for instance
doing covid now to fit differential
equations
yeah yeah right okay so it's super
useful for that
um well i mean that's the coming you
know that's the idea of using machine
learning
for differential equation solutions for
example no
yes no this is parameters in
differential equations and now you can
adapt them
yeah but actually i i think steven is
right and and
and not only i mean part of the stuff i
did with sensitivity for optimization is
is a is from a paper about using using
optimization and machine learning and
and one of the things these
parametric functions allow us to do is
provide the correct derivatives and and
i have a design for that
we'll want to talk about probably later
in the machine learning meeting
that allows you to get the the
derivatives needed for the back
propagation
process okay so there's two different
ways around here
one thing is using these parametric
functions to provide
the thing that is going to be fed to you
know
to represent the the automatic
differentiation so to speak
another different thing that i was
saying is that the workflow
of approximating at the solutions to a
differential equation by neural nets
as opposed to approximating them by
these parametric functions
is something that should be uniform in
this workflow that is
you should be it should just be a method
choice whether you're going to use one
of these parametric functions
i don't think it's the same i think
you're both confused
that's that's different that's different
i think you're both confused
so so the idea of using uh
neural nets to approximate differential
equations that will need
sort of obviously an actual function
representation when it comes out
but it's not parametric there's nothing
parametric about it
why that's the whole point that's the
whole point is to make something
where it's not just a particular neural
net solution
it's not just a particular differential
equation solution but a whole family of
differential equation solutions
where you don't have to solve each
individual one but you're just using the
neural net to interpolate
okay so in that sense it is similar yeah
or or a
related idea well in particular
predict for example one you know predict
returns a prediction predictor function
right which to me sounds very similar to
the parametric
function
now it's it maybe it's different in the
sense that
the predictor function typically is
being fed
large lumps of data and predicting you
know the score the chance that the
spacecraft blows up or whatever it is
right but
whereas here you're feeding in a small
number
this parametric function is different in
the sense that this one
understands the underlying problem what
it does
it does a partial compile effectively
now
when you then feed it parameters you
know
it's it's much much faster to get to the
solution i i get it i get it i'm saying
i don't think there are actually
different things i think that what's
happening
is again you could imagine a predict
a a parametric function that
emits a predictor function that is
parameterized by parameters
that then can be applied to data right
so it's a two-step thing the parametric
function
emits a function the function is then
applied to actual values or data
right possibly yeah
i think so i think the predictor
function is largely on
i mean even if i'm in there i don't
really know what's in it i think it's a
goggle
it's sort of you know a mix of the bag
of methods
used for predict exactly exactly that is
correct
but what i'm saying is you could imagine
a setup
where there is a parametric where where
okay
where a predictor function where its
output
is a predictor function
right as opposed to its output being a
number like separation
yeah sure yeah sure right absolutely so
you know
and and to me this is a mechanism for
something that we have not had
right but which i think we've had
interest in which is neural nets that
emit
neural nets so to speak i see well in
that case we are talking about this
conceptually the same
i think so i think so and i think that's
what happens in
i don't know you know um i mean it's not
quite the same as reinforcement learning
again but it's again these are all
related concepts
anyway talk to ethan and those guys
about this i think there's some
unification here
that can be done um
so the other thing that you can do
here which is quite important is to
compute
the sensitivity let's say you have an
optimal solution
yeah i get it how sensitive is it with
respect to changes in some
underlying assumptions so what's the
default for this primal minimum value
why is
why is the first example not the default
example
the default the default we chose to to
to be consistent with the other
up convex optimization function which is
to provide
rules for the results so if you want to
plot it you
easily you do that
versus that the next example shows that
the default
the default output in terms of the rules
so they're interesting here is to see
how the optimal value depends on the two
parameters
whereas the default is to get the actual
location of the optimal
optimal variable values as opposed to
the optimal
um objective value
say that again what it gets you the
variables x and y are the variables in
the second example there
yes okay but the objective is abs x plus
two
y minus three the value of that
objective for the different parameters
is effectively what we plotted in the
example above but it's basically like
n argument versus and min value
yeah i understand but what isn't what
we've done for minimize
to give the value and then give a list
of rules for the position you don't
want that you know you for for easy
processing you don't want a composite
output like that
if it was an association you'd be a
happy person
you still have to then deal with it and
take things out and
but would you but i don't understand you
have to specify what you want
somehow right yes yes and so many of our
functions
you know if you don't tell them anything
they'll just give you an association
but they have an additional argument
which is a property argument which
then either is a auto extractor into the
association that's what conceptually you
can think of it as
sure or it shortcuts the actual
computation
so why is that not how these work
uh because i don't think you want that
whole association most of the time
i agree i agree so the only question is
but look the question is in this case
it seems and also i don't know what the
cost is if you were to i mean
they usually have a lot of properties
that's a long list fine but but so what
you're saying is
normally you want a particular property
right yes
okay or a set of properties yeah that's
fine
but then then the default case
is i'm just objecting
to the fact that the default case gives
you a property incompatible with what
minimize gives you
since the default case my guesses will
not be used very often
the the more common case will be
something where you're specifying i want
the primal this that knowledge
i would i would disagree with that i
think we chose the default case to be
the
rules because that's that's the case
that's that's very commonly used
because people typically want to you
know if they want to post-process the
result they want to know whether
if they want to if they want to find out
what the the minimum value was they just
you know take the objective and do slash
dot the rules
which they get out which is the default
so it's really convenient whereas with
in minimize you have to do you know part
of
result two i know did you so this is
everything the question is why is this
compatible with that minimize
it's not it isn't it isn't you know we
we
all of these convicts of optimization
functions they
return they have this return value as
opposed to that composite return
value fine you know and they can report
so many more things that we can't ever
do
for general optimization and it's quite
easy to mimic the n minimize return
value by just a list of those two
two of those properties i agree
i understand yeah all right
i mean i don't know this field well so i
don't really know i mean things like
this so just think
whatever i don't know this stuff well
this is what we introduced for
for for sort of our convex optimization
that we can have matrix variables and
and vector variables and so on which is
very very
which makes the the formulations very
compact and almost i would say that
they're close to impossible without that
um and
use cases for this why would you want
this this kind of function so here's a
couple
let's say that you wanna and since you
were
talking we talked about games the other
day yep
let's say that you wanna maximize the
minimum
okay so you have some variables that we
call parameters here
but you want to maximize outside of that
minimization
you can now do that okay
jump saying yeah nested
type of of or hierarchical optimization
problems
yeah that's cool okay another case which
is basically more or less similar which
is like when you do vector optimization
meaning or multi-objective optimization
then what you typically want to compute
is the pareto surface
of optimal solutions yep so you don't
just get one solution you get a whole
surface
that means you solve a shitload of
optimization problems
and they're usually called scalarization
methods they map it to
a what what our optimization methods are
a scalar optimization methods
yep but you're going to solve a lot of
them
okay uh stochastic and robust
are similarly where you deal with
parameters in other ways where you
they're equivalent to solving many many
optimization problems
so i can talk about those two but do you
understand robust roughly
yeah i think that there's a good
application example we haven't really
filled that out that much yet but i
think that there's a few
okay robust let me explain what that is
then
so robust if you have these parameters
what is the safe optimization
value that you should use
so let's say that i want to you know um
i want to minimize something but there's
some uncertainty
in my parameter values and the way i
express uncertainty here is
deterministic
uncertainty by that i mean the
parameters live in a set
under the dose by the way are you sure
you want to use this thing
for in a um to represent function i
think you should say function here
you think this is fine i can change that
to function i really would i mean i i'm
a big fan of introducing this more
seriously in the language but i don't
think people know it enough yet
yeah fair enough and i think it's quite
expressive but yes
i think it's great and that's why i want
to make political bar dash
greater than produce it so people will
use it routinely
um go ahead
but but the mission okay so you're going
to minimize something and you have
this uncertain uncertainty meaning the
parameters
given a set now what's the
what's the worst case minimum that you
can get
you know it's almost it's basically like
maximizing with respect to the
parameters effectively
or you could say that you want the
minimum that's that can be valid for
all possible values of those parameters
yeah i get it so you have it how do you
wait i mean i don't understand
in the for all thing it's like it's most
important for it to be
good for these values of parameters no
you don't do that you just say for all
so it has to be be possible
it has to be valid for all possible
parameter values
the problem with that for all is that
you can't eliminate it
so it becomes what's called an infinite
optimization problem
so you have basically an infinite number
of conditions yeah i get it
right so where is so can we write that
with a for all here
we can't right now we've just made that
possible in the symbolic case
um so if there's an optimization
you can we should probably actually rob
i didn't think of that here but we
should probably
parse and accept for all maybe why not
but i mean so you're saying that in
minimize
i can have a for all in it you can
soon okay okay
yes yeah but that well i mean that
the yeah i think the for all kind of
makes sense but we'd have to include the
parametric constraints within the for
all that right exactly
yeah it just needs to be parsed out in
the right place but we could do it and
it would be
kind of a kind of a consistent make it
clear wouldn't it
yes it would make it clear because
that's exactly what it means
where is the for all in this in this
statement otherwise
the the either state that would be that
would be for all that that 10x
where you see the x variables there will
be a for all in front of that
and then these these parameters um
um a beta and alpha
would there's an and you know that list
represents an and first of all
yep okay so there's an end of those two
conditions on x and y
there's a for all in front of those and
then those two conditions on the
parameters
alpha beta would be the for all
condition
this is the second argument overall
you know it's a thread what the
i mean for all takes three arguments
sorry i mean it will be for all alpha
beta
yes and then you put those last just
those last two
that that only have alphas and betas in
them
okay um you would take
understanding that but i believe you
that i
i don't think we need to go i mean the
only thing i'm confused about is usually
for all has a payload
yeah but then the the payload is the
last payload is those x and y
inequalities the end of those two that's
the actual ultimate payload
i see so it's a predicate it's saying
for all alpha and beta
these inequalities are supposed to be
valid
no almost you have to they're
in two different one is conditions on
the on the quantified variables
and the conditions on quantified
variables gets put
um but but this is a list of both
these are the quantified variables at
the end right
yes yes and so this list met
mixes non-quantified variables with
quantified variables
exactly so the x and y are free within
the for all i i get it
yeah yes
yeah that's the issue
um hmm
well i mean the syntax you have right
now seems to me perfectly sensible for
that
whether there's a for all syntax that's
clear i don't it's also identical to the
the um sorry
the uh the parametric optimization
and it will be more or less identical to
the stochastic optimization
so the only case we'll say alpha and
beta are picked from some
stochastic distribution exactly yes
yes so so normally here
you could say x element of blah blah
blah here is that correct
yes you can do that in that in that
argument
as opposed to in this argument
which argument do you put that in or do
you put it in this constraint
you can put it you can put it in if if
that if that element depends on the
parameters
i'd think you have to put it in the in
that constraint set but if
if it's you know it's say x okay i think
it's a good
puncher it can go either place okay
okay so in other words you could also
say alpha is distributed like
a normal distribution with blah blah
blah and that could go in the constraint
argument there yes
okay okay cool um
all right a question on our live stream
about whether
there is people saying this looks like
very well
seth saying it looks extremely useful
good somebody else saying it looks
nice but too mathy look this stuff is
complicated stuff
right this is when you need it you
really need it
and that's what it's for when you if
you've
you know it will be used implicitly in a
lot of places that was what we were
talking about a little bit earlier
um where you might not have known that
under the hood it's using fancy
convex optimization and so on so the
other thing that's happening in the
world
generally so when we could just barely
compute things that you couldn't really
deal with parameters or uncertainty yeah
now progressively you know we want to
deal with uncertainty
in in more and more so we can assess
reliability and robustness of our
understanding so when you can do a whole
a whole family of computations you can
assess robustness and so on
yes so that's starting to happen and
this is going to take some time to flow
into all of our
solvers but um but that's
progressively what's happening good
so okay let's let's so there's a
question here about is it useful for
hyper parameter optimization in neural
networks
do you know
um no i don't know but but there is
you know i mean hyper parameters are
usually sort of distributionally bottled
so that's kind of falls into the
stochastic realm
something to ask at here um
yeah these are things when you want to
have kind of a
what's the safe return on that portfolio
given certain uncertainty in
right in um that's right
right or you're going to make a an
actual engineering design where there's
certain variability in components
but you want to guarantee that it will
function right so here's a question from
nick on our live stream which i think is
a good question
which is are there going to be wrappers
for specific kinds of problems like
routing scheduling and so on
yes we already have a bunch of them but
but there's there's more coming many
more coming what's an example of a
wrapper for like routing
well there's a there's a ton of them in
graph graph computations like the whole
maximum flow there's a there's a lot of
data
flow use this stuff no max flow is
usually
this basically max flow is basically
linear programming but on specialized
structures that can utilize those
structures very directly
okay but so so
in the family of things that i mean
scheduling routing etc
that directly use convex optimization i
mean yeah what is the so
one one of the limitations okay in in
the in the setup for
for the max flow problems and and
shortest path and all of those things
is that you can only you can only that
there's a slightly rigid
the family of problems that you can
formulate if you want a richer problem
description language
you need to go to optimization so
scheduling
basic scheduling can be done with those
flow problems in graphs
but if you want something more general
it becomes an optimization problem and
now you're in this business
some of which are convex some of which
are non-complex okay the question is the
wrapper
for you know i've got a specific problem
i'm trying to
do you know a routing problem for i
don't know
microprocessor design or something right
how do i formulate that problem in terms
of is that problem
i mean this is like you know we got
whole things like system modeler
to formulate things as differential
equations what is the analogous thing i
mean these old systems out of what was
called ampl some of these very old
systems for doing mathematical
programming whatever they were well
ample
is actually for optimization pure and
simple
okay um it's like our symbolic layer
here
okay fine it's actually very good it's
not bad
you know it's very old but it was done
by brian kernighan and
and richard foreign these people so it
was pretty good
but so okay but so what is the higher
level description language relevant for
these problems
yeah so so our
okay often you have a domain description
language that's
more specialized to the domain in
question yeah right
so that it becomes easier to formulate
these problems
both both to express them and express
them shorter
now look that's what we've after a
decade that's what we've done for pdes
we're finally getting a nice description
language that actually lets you
compute fairly easily you know a bunch
of pde situations so i guess i'm asking
what the analog of that in this is
well but we've added many more
description languages we've added a
description language for graphs we've
added one for probability and statistics
we've added no i understand but so i'm
asking what are the ones
which are heavy lifting you know
problems that get
solved with complex optimization what
are those kinds of domains like in
robotics is there is there there's a
domain in robotics isn't there where you
use this kind of stuff
yeah true but it's significant to to to
develop these domains
each one of them so that's that's a
pretty
because the minute you introduce let's
say robotics you don't want just that
no i'm aware i'm aware so i'm asking
what are those domains and what is the
map of what
you know each domain is has a certain
cost to introduce it and to get deep
enough
and general enough that it's usable so
i'm asking what are those domains
well i can they touch
more or less every domain that we work
on and many that we haven't worked on
so you know control theory signal
processing
image processing uh okay
learning statistical generic right right
i'm asking for things which were we
don't have
a dog yet in that fight
so i'm saying i mean something like
machine learning we obviously have tons
of stuff already there
i'm asking are there areas we don't have
stuff in
that because you know machine learning
we can do a bunch of stuff right now
is this useful for hyper parameter
optimization we don't know
right i don't know it seems like a
strangely asked question to begin with
no it's not a strange question
hyperparameter optimization is a thing
it hasn't it's quite
quite as popular now as it was maybe two
or three years ago but that was kind of
the
you know a peak issue for for neural
nets
is you know it's sort of how do you get
the best network to train for some
particular thing
it would be an obvious application of
this if those optimization problems
have the right structure to be convex
optimization which i have no idea
i don't know either not exactly i think
i think it's unlikely too right but i
think it's a question to ask etienne
you know so that's the question of sort
of what rate have these domains been
uh formulated as optimization and then
secondly recognize this convex
optimization
i i understand i understand okay just
like so in economics
in finance that's progressed pretty far
in control theory and signal processing
that's progressed very
far in um
some of these routing problems that you
talk about like circuit routing i mean
we do routing for graph layout
but it's very simplistic routing um
but but there's we have a bunch of
application example that our layout
effectively layout and routing problems
right but the question is when do we get
the wrappers
that allow people to easily be able to
formulate routing problems
using these things where we don't where
you don't have we don't have them
we i don't have a plan for you know we i
have a
big list and there's a question of what
rate that we can sort of portion
so so most likely those things should
not initially be built
i mean like like for example i remember
we had an example that was in the 12-1
uh blog post and things like that there
was an example
of um uh using convex optimization to
pick uh to figure out how to pack
um certain rectangles right sure it was
the same
thing was unbelievably painful to
program
remember how painful that was to program
yeah it took it took some effort right
so my question is
what is the family of problems that are
like that and is there a domain specific
way of describing those
but do you think of that as a new domain
or an existing domain
that's a new domain it's a new domain
it's really a new domain
it's not you know it's not machine
learning it's not image processing
it's something different it's some thing
where we you know
that one might reasonably say you know
some planning
optimization type thing that isn't
something we're currently doing
okay
right so
okay yeah i mean as i said it's it's all
over the place in chemistry it's it's
it's
at the right time i understand i
understand so so there are two questions
here
question one we've got existing
functionality can we use these
algorithms
in that existing functionality that's
question one which it sounded like
you've done some work
on but it's not clear that that's gone
all the way no it's not gone all the way
fine second question is are there
new preferably horizontal areas
that are can be attacked and and
for example that floor up to you know
floor area optimization thing
i don't know what the general class of
problems like that is
and whether there is a simple to
describe class of problems or whether i
mean you know
to give one example like in the setup of
differential equations
by the time you have to have a whole
system model a system
to set up the differential equations
that's not as simple to deal with domain
right that's right even even the pde
domain it's clearly
fairly complex to define pdes with all
their boundary conditions et cetera et
cetera et cetera
so what i'm asking is are there any
areas
in the area of various kinds of
scheduling and all this kind of thing
that are like here's an example and i
don't know whether this is an
optimization problem
of this type or not okay question that
came up
for you know for random schools right
now
they're asking the question they say
okay
uh we're gonna have we're gonna break
the classes in in
in group in four groups right and people
could i'm not sure it's a good social
idea but but you know let's imagine
that everybody could pick who their top
you know
friends you know the top people who
they'd like to be in the same group as
them
are do you understand what i'm saying
yeah
yeah and and then they and then the
question is can you allocate groups
to give people their most satisfying
kind of thing
somebody that doesn't have themselves on
mutant and making all kinds of
background noise
um the uh
i think um but so is that an example of
something
which would be um uh
possibly so i had a giant i still have a
giant list of that
and initially i set out for 12 1 that we
were to focus on applications
it was very hard for us to execute in
the team
okay well i i understand but i'm asking
it could be the case okay that there are
no
kind of easy to access horizontal
applications
right it could be the case that every
application area is a pretty tall
vertical tower
right that requires significant support
as systems engineering does
you know as pde solving does that to set
up these problems
you know is complicated and requires
lots of domain knowledge
right i don't know that's what i'm
asking
right and uh um
you know by the way a couple of things
on our live stream here they're just
some questions of interest which i think
i know the answer to but
push is asking is simulated annealing
and so on used in these optimizations i
would think
yes somewhere but these are much more
powerful general techniques
that are fair yeah so yes so
one of the the topics which we already
have a
function for and minimize uses
some of these non-deterministic methods
like simulated annealing
there will be updates to those functions
too both to add
what's called deterministic methods that
will guarantee globality
and these non-deterministic methods will
which will not guarantee globality but
it's sometimes the only choice you have
right guaranteeing globality just seems
like one of those super difficult things
yeah convicts is one that does it no and
we have and we have a line to now
to many more domains that we can do it
for okay but so
look in the in the history of these
things i think you've even explained
this to me i mean back in the day
you know you approximate everything with
linear stuff and then you do linear
programming
the you know the point here is that now
we can do
convex optimization almost as
efficiently as linear programming
and therefore and now there's a question
of well now there is another kind of
approximation that can be done
and you know we can do that now the
question here
and that's effectively part of what's
happening some of it is happening
in the different domains as you call it
when people recognize this yeah you can
confidently say that your problem is
solved
right i understand but so what you're
saying is you know you might be able to
solve airline scheduling you know which
has been traditionally done with linear
programming
maybe there's a with some extra twiddle
of that
there's now there's a version that can
be done with convex optimization i don't
know
well i mean so first of all
linear programming is convex
optimization i understand but it's an
example but the
thing for airline scheduling is might be
you want to make it robust for instance
you want to make it
and we've all seen what happens when
it's not robust right
well fair enough okay so i think there's
a question here
about lagrange multipliers which i
assume are the way that you do
uh a bunch of of um constraints but i
don't really know
that's that's that's the dual the dual
problem we don't we don't describe one
for robust
convex optimization but but we do for
you know parameter optimization and
these other optimizations so the dual
problem
is using lagrange multipliers as
i mean the lagrange multipliers allow
you to have put in a constraint
on what you're optimizing is that right
well they're confused the dual problem
is basically giving you what the
lagrange multipliers are for the
oh i see for that do we
and when we describe the dual problem
might be nice i'm sure we do and perhaps
we should
yeah sounds like a good idea now various
comments here about how
confusion about why this isn't related
more related to machine learning
but because you know the claim is
machine learning training is just
optimization yes it is but it probably
isn't this type of optimization
is that a true statement or is that not
a true statement no it's true
machine learning is full of local minima
um which is what you typically want i
mean i mean
bashing through to a more global minimum
is what you want but finding
the true global minimum is something
you're very unlikely to achieve
yeah but but this this might you know
one of these things might be a
might be a a layer in a in a machine
learning thing
right so that's what we need to you know
that's what you guys need to talk to
attorney about
yeah all right let's have a quick look
here and i want to see your api thing
then we've got a wrap
um okay local optimization
all right vector optimization
what is adjoint i know directional
derivative why isn't that just grad
what is direction
scalar i mean so okay so this is
something rob wanted to bring up it's
not fully cooked but we wanted to hear
your opinion about it
um and this is something so directional
derivative it's an elementary
topic comes up in the first calculus
class and that's like
if you point in this direction what is
the size of the derivative so it's a
scalar value not the gradient you can
compute it
oh i think it's basically that yeah okay
the projection of the gradient in that
direction exactly yes yep
and the thing i call the adjoint
derivative i'm not i haven't figured out
a good name for it but it is
it is effectively the gradient so this
is this is the sort of thing that that
machine learning uses for back
propagation
but why isn't it just called grad
because we have a function grad that's
symbolic that just
computes it we want we want something
like it's so it's like an operator form
like derivative
versus grad which is a symbolic form
you have to open the pages but as i said
and i did talk to some of the machine
learning people about this and they said
the essential thing is that it doesn't
try to evaluate things symbolically
right so this is basically a thing i see
so it's it's the analog
of derivative why
okay directional derivative
what is its second argument i mean
directional derivative has to have an
argument oh i see the directional
derivative is going to have
an order and it's going to have a
direction probably no it's going to
so so we this this design here came up
with
with discussion with jose and he says so
so
it has a direction instead of an order
so it's always a first order thing
okay so it has a direction instead of
whatever list
wasn't why aren't those d sub i's
well this came like i said this came up
with discussion with with was holding
okay so my suggestion would be that that
is in a list
there and that way it gives you the
possibility of having additional
arguments
to that directional derivative thing and
i i think the name directional
derivative makes sense
yeah and it but but i mean what you can
do there is just like we say
so so also i don't understand how you
would do this oh i see the issue is
that those d sub i are going with the
positional arguments x sub i
in here right precisely precisely yeah
right and so so then
but if that was a vector valued function
i mean a vector eating function
um so these those d sub i's can be
each of those d sub is can themselves be
vectors
just like if this thing is eating
vectors here
then then that would be a vector that
expects to eat a vector here
yep right so that the structure of the
d's has to correspond
exactly to the structure of the the x
sub i
i wouldn't call them d though i mean
really wouldn't call them d
that suggests dimension i mean it is it
is
i don't know what you call them but it's
a it's a you know that
is it's a vector v or something maybe
maybe i could call them v
or something yes v v might be better
um the uh
uh okay so so adjoint
means what again so i understand the
directional case
the adjoint is in the sense that instead
so the directional derivative you take
the jacobian and dot with the vector
and that gives you the derivative in
that direction yep okay the adjoint you
take the adjoint or the transpose of the
jacobian
and dot with the i called it delta here
i'm not sure quite what the name to come
in in the reverse ad literature they
call it they use a bar for the notation
um but basically these are going in a
decent direction we should we should
discuss these in more detail but this
doesn't look crazy
okay good i just wanted to hear you say
that stephen yeah right
no i think i think he's actually looking
but we could talk about this more when
we have i think we have a machine
learning meeting
that i'm in next week or the week
following fine let me see the api
documentation
okay ready to share yep
okay sure okay
so let's see so this is should i make
this bigger to see
i mean i can see but i think it'll be
helpful to other people yeah okay
so one yeah 125. okay
now make it bigger on your screen yeah
there we go okay so so can you just show
me
a piece about okay
lovely what does the api look like
okay so the api looks like this you do
register
register optimization what do you
actually send the the creature
okay you centered associations um so we
have an example um
where we actually crudely use find
minimum
as a method so this is what you set so
you say
we're going to call this method the find
minimum method okay so it's going to be
it's going to be accessible from the
method option is that correct
that's right so if you you then then you
then do it in fact
here's the here's the example you just
use method goes to find minimum and it
uses this method
okay so let's see the association okay
the association
is you give it is that the function
which is supposed to cause
the fact that you use use the nice
barred arrow thing for the function
function
you use the word association for an
association is not very consistent
especially since you use an association
i've actually got i've when i first
wrote this i was used to using
association but
you notice i've i've noticed this
notation
so i'm slowly converting that's right
but yes yes i that's that's easy enough
to change
okay so so basically you say okay what
what types of constraints does this
method support
okay okay and and how does so that's the
capabilities list of some kind
that's a capability exactly where does
it feed
into the animal so to speak where does
it where does it actually how does it
take the problem that you have provided
okay and you know so it gives an
association
this problem data is an association okay
and it has
it has a bunch of fields like objective
vector when the objectives
um
the actual problem data
so i mean one of the questions that i
would ask is if you look at
um some of our you know an external
evaluate
okay external evaluate with respect to
many languages
can just feed you know can convert our
data structures to the data structures
of those languages
and coming soon is external function
which will do that for things like c
plus plus am i making sense
yeah yeah and so for example if the
thing is in a dynamic library if that's
how it works
then you know some of these things then
you should be able to do a fairly direct
uh you know call like that
um but i guess i'm going to ask the
question you know if you take
one of those random you know
uh you know the the gurobies and
suplexes of this world and so on yeah
what is their interface
what does it look like their interface
is typically
i mean the interface we're using to do
those is a is a library interface and
basically the interface works like this
is you set up a
you set up a model and then you add
constraints to it
okay and then you you solve okay
i understand what you're saying but i
understand but what we have is things
like you know
x squared plus three x plus whatever a
symbolic displacement
so this this problem date so so
basically those model setups will take
an objective in the form of a vector
okay and that's exactly what this is and
they'll also take constraints
specifications
in terms of what type of constraint it
is and that's what these
what i call cone specifications here
that's what the constraint
specifications are isn't it
okay it's quality turn this thing into
essentially arrays
i mean you've turned it yes as
as a thing so so there's a a big pack of
a packet of arrays
and basically what these animals eat
their food
they're not herbivorous they're array
everest
yes and typically they they eat sparse
arrays
oh sparse arrays how do you specify a
sparse array to them
well you just we we just we just have a
sparse array and then library link
supports a sparse array interface
but what does it feed the animal is a c
plus plus animal or something
right how does the animal eat a sparse
array
i mean i understand how you'd eat an
array well even that is kind of common
well typically
you know different ones have different
interfaces for them
for example you know mkl takes a takes a
takes a compressed sparse row interface
which is very much like we have but of
course i'm trying to get this
changed to be consistent with libraries
like we have an inconsistent thing which
we're waiting to get
that in development supply okay others
take a position
okay okay so hold on hold on what you're
telling me is
there are certain native sparse array
formats like an array
if you're passing an array to a c plus
plus program if it's a one-dimensional
array there's not a heck of a lot of
choice about how it gets passed
precisely yeah if it's a two-dimensional
array there's already some issues but
you know whatever if you're passing a
sparse array it's significantly more
complicated because there's probably
five different ways you might pass it
well there's typically only
two two different ways one is like
sparse row or column and the other is
this you know
index value but when you say that
okay you're saying by saying index value
for example
that's a you know that's a struct or
something in the c plus plus code
presumably
i don't know is it is it something else
it's an array of structs so what is it
well what's what most of these things
take an array of
row index array of column index and
array of values
all right it's just like fortran so just
like for a train yeah
okay okay good to see that things have
been modernized over all these years
okay so the thing is you know
uh you know
um you know it's a ray everest it eats a
raise
you have to just feed it a sequence of
arrays and
what i'm trying to understand is you
know in the end
you know we have glue code that you know
we've had since
1989 or something for doing installs of
external programs
right where where you have a c function
now we are modernizing that stuff that's
a piece of work
that is coming out of i don't know
christopher did some work on this a
couple of years ago
now it's being put into the the tooling
stuff he's doing
for the compiler etc are you aware of
this stuff at all
yes i've been i've been involved with
the meetings that christopher's talking
about some of the tooling stuff for the
compiler okay great and i think i think
the compiler
will actually provide a really good
interface to various
various c programs that's what i'm
imagining because i think the
the overall architecture there which
christopher's been pushing for a couple
of years
is to be able to make external function
work with c programs
okay so external function will work with
an interpreted language like python or
something
but it also should work with c and for
that it has to be able to define a data
structure
a struct an array of structs whatever
else define a
and then essentially be able to
automatically convert
our expressions to that form yes and
one of the one of the things i want to
do i mean we're waiting for
the graph group to finish is to
to to fix the index thing with the
sparse arrays
but one of the things i want to do is is
and we've basically got prototype code
to start doing it is put sparse array
into the compiler
then we can actually write all of our
sparse code with the compiler and
interface to libraries really
conveniently
exactly i understand except that as you
say
these libraries have multiple different
forms and that's what i'm pushing on
is we need a language basically to
describe
you know that it isn't really a data
type conversion because it's not just
data types it's it's not just yeah but
see within the compiler if we have
sparse array in the compiler then then
all we have to do
is write a new data structure and just
write a conversion to that data
structure within the compiler
i understand that and right but i can i
can
that is assuming it is not just the data
structure
it is also the meaning of the data
structure you know in other words
you know let's say people have i don't
know just a two dimensional array it
could mean two different things let's
say it's just
multiple different things there's gonna
have to be some
you know glue layer in which we define
what those
what those possible forms in which a you
know ultimately the series of bits
that uh you know are emitted to
represent a sparse array of a certain
kind
yes yes okay so i mean but but
you think there's a tool chain there
that goes through the compiler
through extern i mean is it you know in
the end when you call one of these
things
it will be a library load i mean will
you be saying library load to get this
thing in or what will you be doing
well right now what we're doing is we're
using this library link
to do it but yes ultimately with once
once
once this stuff is more incorporating
the compiler i think we'll be able to
just do a library load
and and so as a practical matter when
these external optimization libraries
when you buy one of these things
do you get a blob of code that they
expect
you will link like that is that how they
intended to be used
no when you buy what so so bo all the
libraries we've done so far with what
they do is they give you
you know you they they you know you can
download the libraries as you want
okay and they give you a license that
unlocks
libraries basically so what so the model
we're using now
is we're putting we're putting together
packets that'll be available by the
packet server
okay and you could do say method goes to
gerobi or something
and what that'll do is it'll it'll go to
the package if the first time you do
that i'll go to the packet server
get the paclet and then it'll you know
and we have an automatic thing that
checks your license to make sure you
have a license for it
and then it subsequently it just we have
the libraries in the system
so it knows where to find okay so i
understand so the way we're doing it
with these companies
is um that uh
they are giving us the bag of bits for
their libraries
yep and then there is an authentication
mechanism and i assume that's working
through our whole authentication
system is it that
no no it's working through their
licenses no i know that
i know that i know that we've got a
whole system that's been built
right for doing i don't know whether
they're using oauth 2 or whether they're
not using something as modern as that
but we've got a whole system built you
know if you for example want to use the
facebook api
right there's a whole system where
you're using our thing
but you have to log into facebook then
we have to get a token back from
facebook
that we can then send to facebook to use
the api
do you get what i'm saying but it's not
like that stephen this is an actual
library
on your system and it's their um
whatever license matters i understand i
i understand that
i i i okay well who knows i mean it's
probably less much less modern than that
i would guess
oh yeah um but but the fact is
the token so is it in the end the
license is some file that sits on your
system or what is it
typically in in both of these i know in
the most that case it's just a file that
sits on your system
okay all right so it's a magic
phenomenon
and that there's probably tied to some
license id on your system
yes okay fine so
okay so then then there is a workflow
presumably which says which tells you
go buy this thing from these guys get
this authentication
piece put it on your system and then
just use method arrow gerobi and it'll
just work is that the idea
right and if you try and use method
gerobi without having the license
it'll complain it'll it'll say you know
please go to and
you know this is part of our partnership
to give the right website right
yeah yeah right yeah right right i get
it it's highly sensible
okay so now another thing is that many
of these libraries are free
for academics so okay that's a whole
complicated in in bizarrely entwined
complexity which i'm sure we can deal
with yeah i think it's just great it
means that
for academics it's it they have an
incentive
you know if you're into this and you you
need to use the absolutely best
you you it's there's no friction to get
it
right and if it's a commercial project
you will get it if it's worth it
right i'm saying if and it's not a
problem
but the question of how our license
mechanism
interfaces with what uh you know what
counts as an academic organization and
how we tag that
that's not our problem we we don't touch
that they go to them
and then say what they are do
you see what i'm saying it's not oh i
see i see so you still have to get a
license key from them it's not like
they're relying
i mean it's not like what we're doing
with single sign-on for example
with universities no well okay i mean
that's something they could do
do you understand what i'm saying
because yeah you know what's happening
we get even deeper in bed and it's
you know i don't know if that's that's
you know that's this is a different
issue for a different group but but i
mean
i'm just to just to paint that picture
the point is with single sign-on
we are using the directory of the
university
right to determine whether the person is
a valid user
right that's how it works
and so and how widely deployed is that
well we just started deploying it it's
being deployed very quickly
and lots and lots of large universities
have now already deployed it it's only
been like a month or something we've
been doing that
great no but i think that i mean i think
that this is
this is i don't think we need to tie
into that
it doesn't you know you don't want a
couple projects that don't have to be
coupled
and so i don't think that these no no i
understand okay we need to wrap here but
but let me just answer these other
questions on our live stream
um is there an ai that recommends
function names we have experimented with
that it is
remarkably difficult seems to be still
something that needs us boring humans
um let's see when is the stochastic
optimization going to be implemented
somebody enthusiastic about
it uh most likely i mean
we can never promise for sure i'm so
sure i'm sorry about that but
are intended is that they will make it
for their next release following 12
2. um ethan is saying
doesn't just want sparse things but
multi-dimensionality
and heterogeneity and so on yeah all of
that stuff that the plan
for the way to be able to pass data is
very general
and basically if you can give if you
give at c
you know uh
declaration we should be able to deal
with it
um that's the idea and i think i need to
run
and this looks good and uh
look forward to seeing all this stuff i
wish i wish i i wish i understood all of
this better
but but you will so all of a sudden you
decided it's interesting and then we'll
have
right now for graphs now we have massive
massive asks every night yeah right
i know how this goes yeah right well i
know it just
it's it's yes i just haven't i mean look
can you solve the problem that i've been
interested in for a long time of
rob i've asked you about this over the
course of like 15 years
of given a does this help with the
following problem
given a graph with
certain graph distances between its
nodes
find a layout in three-dimensional space
for example
such that the euclidean distance
such that the set of euclidean distances
is as close as possible
to the graph distances in other words
that form of graph layout
you you understood the setup yeah yeah i
mean that would be a lovely method to
have for graph layout to be able to do
that
i mean obviously that's qualitatively
what graph layout does but with some
particular you know l2 norm or something
being able to do that problem does is
that a convex optimization problem
i think i mean i remember you sending
this about or several months ago and
and it's not strictly convex but we
could sort of approximate it using some
of the
but on small scale though with uh but so
it's not it is not convex unfortunately
a pity i mean that would be a lovely
method to have for graph layout
even if it's on a comparatively small
scale um
that uh you know that it tries to do
that it will be very useful for many
purposes particularly those of us
interested in modeling space
something something roger has not
mentioned that i think the the convex
will give us a basis for
is is you know so so so so
in addition to this ocassion stuff we
hope to eventually be moving into more
you know more general nonlinear
programming but there are
you know there are classes of nonlinear
programming where you actually have a
chance of
success and one class is a convex
concave
uh you know difference of convex is what
it's called so you have a convex minus
concave plus a concave
concave function and those actually have
some specific methods you can solve and
also using branch and bound with convex
solvers
underneath the hood gives you an extra
extra thing so it's
i did say that but so we have a line of
of of uh of global optimization problems
that are non-convex
but are basically extensions in
the methods yeah okay that'll be
interesting i mean i you know i just
have no idea
how you know it's like some of these
things end up being generic and very
useful
and some of them end up being just like
uh
no but but so yeah i mean like when
dancing comes into you know for
neumann's office and presents this new
idea for a simplex method
and annoyment says like oh that
um and he'd thought of it obviously
but then so then people said they poo
pooed it and said everybody knows their
problems are non-linear
but i understand i understand so people
found a way
to make interesting problems be
approximated by linear
and that works in that case look i play
the let's play that another
round let's play it to solitons let's
play it to wavelets
right people thought with solitons for
example oh we now have these integral
uh pdes integral pdes will be able to
turn
lots of problems that were horrible and
non-linear and undoable
into things that can be solved using
integral pds
that didn't work out
right right so some of these work and
some of them don't in other words
given that you have a particular hammer
that's true
i think convex i think convex has a
it's a pretty good momentum it's one of
the most popular classes at stanford
just to give you
an example and you know so people flow
in from all kinds of departments
what happens in these different areas
and departments is that
they are able to successfully identify
classes in their domain
no i understand so so look the question
is and it's hard to predict
given a particular method how robustly
usable will it be how much is it a
successful attractor
for other things around it and yes you
know
what i mean for example in in you know
in recent times with
our physics project stuff these
multi-way systems and their various
properties
turn out to be a huge attractor turns
out a huge number of things can be
thought about in terms of those
for example the games thing that i was
just doing and and it's just like by the
day we're coming up with more things you
can think of in that way
um right and uh you know it's just i i
would not have predicted that
particularly
but um after the fact it's kind of
obvious why it's happening
um and you know like wavelets have not
had as much of
a you know as many legs as one might
have thought they would unless i'm
missing something
no i agree with you right so i mean it
it
um uh you know and i don't know whether
that's for want of trying or
you know it's it's like like
you know or whether it's just intrinsic
to the lack of robustness of the concept
um anyway all right
great stuff um the uh
um are there's questions here about uh
um
[Music]
and nash embeddings and linear
kissing number problems yeah i don't
know whether those are
are sphere packing problems convex
optimization i suspect they are
no they're not no
okay i need to learn you see this is the
question i mean when you when you have a
problem like that
it's like can it be approximated is it
approximable by these things or not
and do you redefine i mean you know
sometimes the whole structure of the
world is redefined
so that something becomes a solvable
problem i mean indeed
um but that's exactly i mean so when we
said when we introduced these
integer constraints by the time you have
integer constraints it's obviously not
convex
right nevertheless what can happen is
that
what happens there is that we can
approximate these problems
using convex in such a controlled way
that we can actually get the true
solution
right in in reasonable amounts no that's
interesting i mean it's like taking
numerical approximations and then
finding the integer parts and and using
that to get exact results and so on
yes that's effectively what's happening
right
cool all right i gotta run thanks guys
and uh thanks to folks on the live
stream